[Music]
foreign
Cullen and I'm a data science educator
at posit
I work with a team of fellow Educators
who specialize in teaching open source
code First Data science and we are
really excited to be offering a workshop
at posicomp this year
introduction to data science with r
in this video we'll share with you a few
reasons why we think you should join us
the attractive thing about this Workshop
is that it is a positive Academy course
that means you'll learn by doing a
six-week online apprenticeship with a
posit mentor and several co-apprentices
you'll meet as a group twice a week
to work through a realistic project and
to get feedback on your work
at the first meeting each week you'll
have a chance to just work together and
ask questions with your mentor and your
fellow students
at the second meeting you'll present
your work to everyone else this meeting
is not optional but it's the place where
you'll get the personalized feedback
that will help you become a better data
scientist
in between the meetings we'll give you
interactive tutorials that you can
complete to learn the materials for next
week's part of the project
as the project draws to an end it'll be
time for conference we'll see you there
in person during the workshop days and
we'll finish up the project together I
hope to see you there
hi I'm sisama bhikari and I'm one of the
content writers here at Academy
learning with Academy is both fun and
effective because the courses are spread
over a couple of weeks you never feel
like you're drinking from a fire hose
you have time to truly understand a
concept before moving on to the next but
it is more social than a purely online
course you get to meet the same small
group of students and Mentor each week
so it's more fun and supportive way of
learning
I want to share one final reason why you
should join us for this posit Academy
Workshop
if you're interested in learning r
and that is quite simply that it works
we've had great success training
hundreds of data scientists analysts and
researchers
to learn are and to apply it to their
daily work
with Academy we've developed an
evidence-based method for teaching the
Tidy verse that focuses on building
skills and not only learning facts
our approach involves repeated practice
and in-depth feedback
which together form a solid Mastery of r
that lasts
so we hope you'll join us and we look
forward to seeing you online and in
Chicago this September
[Music]